[Musique]
bonjour
installez-vous confortablement et
essayez de vous rappeler le défi le plus
fou que vous ayez réalisé dans votre vie
ça peut être un voyage ça peut être un
projet quelque chose que vous avez fait
seul ou à plusieurs mais en tout cas un
défi dans lequel vous êtes impliqué à
fond
et dont vous êtes fier
c'est bon vous en avez un
maintenant vous êtes vous lancer un défi
cette année là depuis janvier dont vous
parlerai encore dans 10 ans
pas facile
cette question je me la pose chaque
année
histoire que je vais vous raconter je la
vie depuis mes 18 ans et c'est justement
une histoire de défi
je suis quelqu'un d'introverti ce qui
selon moi signifie simplement d'avoir
besoin d'être seul avec soi-même pour
recharger ses batteries et
l'introversion entraîne de la timidité
de la difficulté à oser surtout pendant
l'adolescence et quand on est introverti
et timide on le sait facilement
on stresse quand le professeur fait
l'appel on prépare des sujets de
conversation à l'avance puis au niveau
de la voix ça se sent
c'est pourquoi à 18 ans j'ai commencé à
me lancer un gros défi par an
imaginez l'impact que ça aurait sur
l'introversion et imaginez le nombre
d'histoires que l'on aurait raconté avec
seulement un défi par an
pour apprendre à me lancer des défis
j'ai procédé en plusieurs étapes
la première c'était de me lancer des
défis dans des domaines que je connais
bien mon tout premier défi a été
d'entraîner des jeunes au foot quand
j'ai vu qu'un club cherchait un
entraîneur j'ai naturellement eu envie
de passer mon chemin d'ignorer l'annonce
et pour une fois je me suis dit allez
pourquoi pas j'ai donc entraîné ces
jeunes pendant un an et demi
et ça m'a fait relativiser sur le fait
d'essai de nouvelles choses ça m'a donné
aussi cette fin de t'en rester plus de
défis et ça nous mène à la deuxième
étape la deuxième étape a été de viser
plus haut ça a été de viser plus fou
le meilleur exemple que j'ai pour ça
c'est quand je cherchais un stage de
deux mois sur internet et je passais de
pages en page passé d'annonces en
annonce et je suis tombé sur cette
annonce
l'étude et la conservation de la loutre
à longue queue au Brésil
alors d'abord je me suis demandé mais
qui poste ça sur Internet
ensuite je suis demandé mais qui peut
bien participer à ce genre de programme
à part quelqu'un qui a perdu un gros
pari
où quelqu'un qui se lance un défi par an
c'est donc comme ça que je me suis
retrouvé au Brésil dans une réserve de
loutre
pendant deux mois
et ben ce fut sans hésiter l'une des
meilleures expériences de ma vie
c'était génial de passer de la crainte à
la découverte d'un univers complètement
différent
c'était en 2018 donc j'ai vécu la Coupe
du Monde de mon souvenir
j'ai rencontré des gens incroyables j'ai
découvert mon pays de cœur le Brésil
et j'avais fini par les apprécier cette
petite bête même si elle s'en foutent
et la troisième étape ça a été
d'utiliser cette folie pour réaliser des
choses utiles que ce soit à travers des
associations ou pour moi-même parce que
une fois qu'on allait élever des loutres
au Brésil il n'y a plus de limite
la suite de cette histoire ça a été de
récolter 10000 euros en 6 mois pour un
projet humanitaire ça a été de créer une
association environnementale au Brésil
et ça ne s'arrête pas ça va toujours
plus loin comme la tient un grand
philosophe de Fort Boyard toujours plus
loin toujours plus haut toujours plus
fort ça ne s'arrête jamais et c'est
génial de réaliser des choses dont on
aurait été incapable à 18 ans on voit
une réelle évolution ce fait de galérer
à chaque fois qui nous nourrit qui nous
fait grandir
mais maintenant
prenons un peu de recul sur tout ça
j'ai remarqué que cette sensation
bizarre que l'on a quand on est
introverti et que l'on essaie une
nouvelle chose je l'aperçois plus comme
du stress
et comme de l'excitation
alors bien sûr à toujours cette
sensation qui nous prend à la gorge et
rien d'être devant vous aujourd'hui moi
ça fait une semaine que je dors pas
mais c'est génial à chaque fois de
galérer pour réaliser quelque chose et
elle est toujours plus loin on se voit
grandir ça donne de la confiance en soi
et même au niveau de la voix ça se sent
j'ai remarqué aussi que plus les défis
passent moi je me pose des questions en
fait
j'agis avant de réfléchir je fonce je le
pose plus de questions ça m'évite de
voir tous les problèmes que je vais
avoir après et ça m'aide à prendre mes
décisions je dis oui directement
et pour prendre les défis ne me demandez
pas ce que je vais faire l'année
prochaine en fait c'est des filles je me
pose pas devant une feuille en me
demandant qu'est-ce que j'allais faire
cette année quel animal bizarre je vais
aller élever au Brésil ce que je fais
c'est que dès qu'il y a une opportunité
et ses opportunités on les a tous chaque
année c'est juste que moi une fois par
an je vais dire pourquoi pas
puis je vais regretter puis j'aimerais y
aller
alors un défi bien sûr ce n'est qu'une
moyenne il y a eu des années avec plus
il y aura des années sans défis mais je
me manquais pas pour ça
dernière chose bien sûr il y a eu des
échecs
j'ai parfois visé trop
j'ai parfois été déçu par certains défis
j'ai par exemple cru que faire partie
d'un bureau des étudiants un BDE sur un
super défi pour un introverti mais le
conclure de le concours de popularité
qui va avec
Ben un peu déçu de correspondait pas à
ma personnalité
donc ça m'a déçu j'ai cru que dire à la
plus belle fille du monde selon moi bien
sûr c'est mes goûts mais lui dire que
c'est la plus belle fille du monde dans
les yeux lui expliquer pourquoi ce qui
est totalement fou
c'est horrible
mais c'était trop facile en fait une
fois que ça a été dit ça a été dit il y
a pas eu de construction il y a pas de
galère donc j'ai été déçu aussi par ce
défi
dernier exemple c'était cette année je
voulais construire mon bar au Brésil à
voir mon bar au Brésil mais les
conditions n'étaient pas bonnes ce
projet sera pour une autre année et
depuis de toute façon j'ai trouvé une
super alternative pour cette année
parce que oui vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi je suis là devant vous
aujourd'hui
quand j'ai vu que j'avais l'opportunité
de faire un TEDx je me suis dit que ça
serait l'opportunité d'avoir un public
de moi
et il se trouve que je ne sais pas
chanter
vous voyez venir
je me suis dit pourquoi pas chanter
devant un public alors je ne sais pas
chanter je vous ai donc écrit une
chanson
en fait on a déjà tous rêvé d'être sur
scène d'être chanteur d'être musicien
alors pourquoi ne pas le faire une fois
dans notre vie et puis de toute façon il
y a deux possibilités
soit ça se passe bien et on s'en
souviendra toute notre vie
soit ça se passe pas bien
et on s'en souviendra toute notre vie
la régie c'est quand vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te parle de cette vie au pays des
merveilles on ne voit que des sourires
au pays du tout doux je te parle de
cette vie aux couleurs du soleil
cheveux frisés elle a le thé enchaînant
les veines je te parle de magie forêt
amazonienne prendre un petit Assal poser
devant les baleines je te parle de cette
je te parle de cette fille je te parle
de cette
vie je te parle je sais
[Musique]
une fille d'artiste la journée sur la
planche à la plage
soit il est qui t'arrive
comme un toucan de sa cage
il sort sur tous les problèmes
ils dansent sur ce qui se passe ailleurs
pour les gens qui l'aiment
ils chantent ces histoires de cœur
des histoires de cœur Bella en a elle
jongle avec les conquêtes un peu comme
rognit entre sur la plage et
caille
la belle Isabella même sa meilleure vie
elle tombe par hasard sur un son de CAPI
le regard se croisent sur un son de
Brésil la règle est plutôt simple Quand
tu es dans ce pays
si les de se blesse ça suffit pour une
nuit je te parle de cette
je te parle de cette fille je te parle
de cette vie
je te parle de cette fille
ils savent surtout les pros
il danse sur ceux qui se passe ailleurs
il joue pour les gens qui l'aiment
il chante ces histoires de cœur
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup pour votre bienveillance
merci pour votre gentillesse
waouh
j'ai une dernière chose à vous dire vous
faites désormais partie de cette
aventure vous êtes mon défi 2022 et vous
alors vous allez vous lancer un défi
d'ici décembre merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]